on tuesday august 30th magnus carlson
logged into chess.com and played an epic
57 game match against big fish 1995
aka vladimir fetisayev partway through
it became apparent to spectators that
carlson had a clear goal in mind the
number one rating on the chess.com blitz
leaderboard
grand master hikaru nakamura held the
number one spot with an even 3200 and
that same day probably not
coincidentally hikaru had an incredible
run in the st louis rapid and blitz
gaining around 40 blitz points and
claiming clear first on the official
feed a blitz rating list by a wide
margin
initially fedesave scored well against
carlson but as the number of games grew
carlson's edge became more apparent
still with every win carlson would gain
only a handful of points while losses
and even draws set him back
significantly
as dawn approached in norway carlson
broke through
first tying nakamura's mark with 3200
exactly and then with one more win
hitting 3204 and claiming clear first on
the leaderboard
carlson had made one previous attempt to
top the leaderboard back in 2020 on a
semi-anonymous account and fedesave had
been one of the stiff defenders who held
him off at that time one of my personal
favorite moments was the following
incredible swindle that even had carlson
laughing and my peephone is not like
magically
oh my
oh
i just assumed
he would take the just last week
chess.com announced an offer to acquire
play magnus the offer has been
unanimously accepted by the play magnus
ford although the process is pending
fans naturally hope to see magnus in
more events in matches such as this one
on chess.com and magnus himself spoke to
that in the announcement video i'm
excited to um
to play in the speed chess championship
again um i have a score to settle
obviously after the last time i played
and lost in the semifinals
but
generally just happy to be playing
top top level events on on a regular
basis
the following game the 49th was probably
the most memorable of the match carlson
plays down an entire rook but showcases
the power of the bishop pair and past
pawns and ultimately wins with a
spectacular and very pretty finish
[Music]
magnus opens the game here with one c4
we get c5 knight f3 g6 and d4 bishop g7
and quantum d5 so right out of the gate
we're getting an imbalance here with
this big pawn center for magnus actually
this is an imbalance that magnus and
vedaseyev have played with before in
fact this imbalance existed in both of
their 2021 world cup games so magnus and
fedesaev have played each side of this
kind of pawn structure and actually
magnus won both of those games and they
were two of the most brilliant games in
that particular world cup so here we now
get pawn to d6 e4 bishop g4 pinning the
knight and bishop d3 which is maybe a
little bit odd because you're allowing
this pin to persist and opening up to
the possibility of knight to d7 and then
knight to e5 which will gain a tempo on
the bishop and will be a little more
effective than if the bishop was on e2
which is more popular so now we get
knight to d7 knight to d2 and in this
position 95 makes a lot of sense white's
going to get an advantage after this
move but it will lead to some trades and
black is going to be down in space so
getting more pieces off the board is
generally in black's interest when
there's less space
but instead we get pawn to a6 and now h3
and one last chance you can play knight
e5 here even though your bishop was just
attacked because 95 will attack this
loose bishop on d3 and the computer
definitely thinks that at this point 95
was the best idea
so bishop takes f3 instead though we're
going to get an imbalance with the
bishop pair
against the knights it's going to be
important in this game and now knight
takes f3 pawn to b5 now often white
really isn't in a position to take this
too advantageously anyway because of
positional pressure you can think of the
bimco gambit but here white actually
just doesn't want to go and capture this
because if you do bishop takes b5
there's queen a5 check which would be a
blunder that magnus carlsen is just
never going to make
so instead after pawn to b5 white goes
ahead and castles and now we get knight
to f6 and rook to e1 rook to b8 so black
is supporting the b-pawn and also
opening up for some pressure here
against b2 at some point if things go
well for feder
so we get rook to b1 and here castles
bishop to d2 and knight to e8 this move
might kind of surprise someone who's new
to chess why would you move your knight
back to the edge of the board it's not
being attacked or anything but 98 is
very very common in these kinds of
positions the knight does like to go to
c7 where it can support this pawn
structure right here sometimes if black
gets good counter play against the
center it can pressure d5 support 26 and
of course the knights retreat opens up
the bishop here to attack b2 it just
have you know lots of room to roam on
the long diagonal here is a really
really nice move from magnus on to b4 i
think a lot of newer players would be
very very reluctant to kind of open up
the queen side when it looks like black
is trying to create pressure there and
black has more pawns you know in a good
strong position on the queen side at the
moment but actually b4 is just a really
great move that's opening up things and
we see that white actually has a lot of
pieces in position to take advantage of
the queen side structure and this is you
know creating more lines for the bishops
which white of course loves as well
so one interesting move the computer
points out here by the way was to meet
this you know advance that creates this
enormous pawn tension with more pawn
tension black could have played pawn to
a5 here which is one of the computer's
favorite moves if you capture over here
like an advanced b4
and white still certainly has an
advantage but black gets a good pawn
structure in a lot of these lines so a5
is a move that i really like on a
positional level
instead though we get um b4 and then c
takes b4 from fedex who now has the c5
square for his knight and pawn takes on
b5 knight c5 gaining a tempo on the
bishop which falls all the way back here
to f1 and pawn to a5 so dream scenario
for fetishive now is you're able to go
and win this pawn right here you've got
good pawns on a5 and b4 and i don't c5
is great if you get all of that then you
know you're doing amazingly in black is
much better which is why magnus now
senses that there's an opportunity and
time is of the essence and he opens
things up with pawn to e5 which is the
best move in the position and a really
really strong move right here so after
pawn to e5 we get pawn takes on e5
knight takes on e5
now fedex cannot play queen takes d5
that might look like that move is just
fantastic but in fact here there's
knight c6 you attack the rook and you
also threaten this fork on e7 a fourth
of the queen and the king and so white
would just win an exchange in this
particular line
so after knight takes e5 we get bishop
takes e5 rook takes e5 knight to d6 the
knights are looking pretty good although
bishop pairs are very strong as we'll
see in this game
bishop to h6 attacking the rook which
now moves over to e8 and in this
position the computer's saying you have
to play something like rook c1 if you
want to maintain the advantage that's
how sharp the position is instead the
natural move queen d4 allows fettuc to
get a pretty good position although the
play is by no means simple
here pawn to f6 of course you really
need to shut down this diagonal right
here because if you leave it open
there's all kinds of moves like rope
takes e7 that would allow checkmate here
if the queen could come in this
direction
so we get pawn f6 the rook is pushed
back it falls back to e1 and the best
move and the best opportunity fetishes
have had in this game would now be
knight to a4 moving the attack tonight
over to the edge of the board but
intending to reintroduce it here on c3
where it would attack the rook this pawn
on a2 and the b5 pawn and the d5 pawn so
knight a4 in this position
is just perfect put that knight on c3
and attack all of the sensitive points
in the position for white but after
queen b6 here instead magnus now gets a
really really good opportunity with
bishop e3 lining up and pinning the
knight here
now the computer says fetis say it needs
to be passive and play a move like rook
c8 rook ec8 or with bc8 to support the
attack knight on c5
but that's really passive it's hard to
play fetisev is an aggressive player he
now tries to move knight a4
unfortunately it's a move later than the
computer thought he should play this
move and now queen d1 is really strong
by magnus he senses that he can create
this double attack hitting the queen and
hitting the knight as a result fedesaith
only has the try here knight c3 meeting
an attack on his queen with an attack on
magnus's queen on d1 and also forking
the rook on b1 bishop takes b6 magnus
goes ahead and takes a fedesav's queen
betta saya takes magnus's queen the
attacked
bishop here
now picks off a pawn bishop takes a5 and
knight c3
now at this point
magnus makes maybe the one mistake that
he makes in this game but i think he
knew the best move and he just wanted to
play the fun move the flashy move which
is fantastic you know as a chess fan we
want to see chess players play who are
trying to entertain as much as they are
trying to win
so the simple move here is just play
rook takes b4 and you pick up the b4
pawn
uh and in this position
basically white is just winning white is
up material white has the bishop pair
and the computer says that this is like
plus five if you let it think for a
while
instead magnus goes down a path where
he's actually going to sacrifice a rook
he plays bishop takes before and by the
way he's still really close to winning
in this line maybe winning with best
play but it's much more complicated so
he's giving fedeser the opportunity to
play knight takes b1
right here
and in this position of course his goal
is not to just recapture on b1 that
would allow fedex to pick off the pawn
on b5 and then fedesav would actually be
doing great instead his point is pawn to
a4
boom these are connected past pawns but
magnus just
resisted the opportunity to recapture
the knight and he's had his rook
captured on b1 so he sacrificed a rook
with this move right here
the point is he's trying to pick up the
knight here on b1
which is trapped by this beautiful
bishop here that just dominates the nine
and then he wants to maintain these
amazing uh connected past pawns if he
has connected past pawns and the bishop
pair he's just going to win very easily
here
but federer has resources so he plays
rook a8 attacking this pawn on a4 if he
can get rid of that pawn then the pawns
are much weaker
than they would be before and it's okay
to give up the knight that is trapped if
you can get this pawn right here
so magnus plays pawn to a5 really trying
to keep the connected past pawns rook to
b8 so he's threatening that a save is
threatening this pawn on b5
pawn to b6
and in this position
knight two a3 which is a really great
move from fetishev uh this move says hey
you gotta capture my head at some point
right and now when you capture my knight
i'm going to take not just this a5 pawn
i'm also going to get the b6 pawn in a
moment and actually you're just down an
exchange and you know black is actually
much much better
so
magnus in this position has no intention
of taking the knight on a3 instead he's
going to stay down a rook he plays rook
takes e7
now this rook is dominating the seventh
rank
he keeps the connected past pawns and he
also manages to fort fetiseive's knights
which is
you know really really unique how often
can you
see a scenario where a bishop is forking
two nights like this
it's a really beautiful situation and
for all of these beautiful things in the
position magnus has only had to continue
to stay down a rook in the position
so here the knights are forked and the
knights must defend each other
the correct way for the knights to
defend each other according to the chess
engine was here to go knight ac4 pulling
the knight back from the edge of the
board where it's been stuck the knights
are now defending each other there's
pressure here on a5 and this position is
super complicated it's still better for
magnus but the computer says that fetis
save can defend here and i'm going to
give a crazy computer line here
it goes rook e6 so putting pressure on
the d6 knight
and in this position we have uh rook
over to d8
bishop takes c4 knight takes c4 magnus
still down a rook but with three past
pawns and now we get uh on to b7
attacking the rook at which point black
has to
desperately try to give back material to
break apart white's threats and white
continues to not accept the material
rook takes a5 here
and then instead of you know capturing
this and then the knight captures and
the pawns are dealt with we have rook c6
hitting the knight and intending rook c6
and also keeping this rook under attack
and then rook b5 leaving the knight
hanging but counter-attacking this
bishop down here
rook c8 leaving everything hanging but
hitting this rook and trying to promote
this pawn on b7 and now we get rook
takes b7
rook takes the 8th check king f7 this is
where the computer line ends
and white still has an extra pawn in
this position
but it's very likely that this pawn is
going to fall because black's king is a
little bit too close to it it's a bit
isolated and difficult to support and
this position is more likely to be a
draw than anything else but all of that
was super complicated this is a 3-0
blitz game you know of course we're not
expecting either player to see these
crazy computer lines and in the game
fede misses this computer chance he
plays knight dc4
so the knights defend each other but in
a bit of a worse fashion maybe fedesev
was
thinking that you know my knight here is
on the rim but on the other hand it's
harder to attack the knights when
they're defending each other over here
whereas when i had them
defending each other in this position
you know then they could be
undermined a little more easily
so they can't
really be undermined or attacked quite
as effectively in this position but it
doesn't matter because magnus now just
dominates the board and he doesn't need
to uh
to go after the knights
so we get pawn to d6 this pawn is
pushing forward
now
this is kind of the last moment as black
that you're just gonna try and spend all
your time and see is there any defense
here but there really isn't the computer
says this is winning for white if you
try and move like h5 which doesn't do
anything but just to put like a passing
move on the board
that says hey how do you beat me white
can just play pawn to d7
and in this position
you know black isn't able to move the
king black isn't able to do anything
productive with the rooks the knights
are stuck defending each other
and
basically it's like zug's wing right
here you know down a rook
and
not really in possession of an immediate
threat white is just winning because
black is just totally stuck for moves
in the game we got a spectacular finish
and it goes knight takes on a5
right trying to get rid of those past
pawns over on the queen side bishop
takes on a3 so magnus has finally
regained some material
knight to c6 attacking the rook on e7
but now bishop to c4 check the king
tries to hide over on h8 and now
bishop to b2
very very pretty so the bishop b2 move
right here
is offering up the rook the rook can be
captured but after knight takes e7 it's
actually this checkmate here on the
board with bishop takes mate so we have
this beautiful bishop checkmate that
features in the remaining lines
so after bishop b2 instead of taking the
rook fetishette tries knight to e5
trying to blunt the attack on the stack
until the threat of bishop takes f6 with
mate but magnus just plays rook takes e5
same idea now if you play pawn takes
bishop takes oh what a way to finish
right magnus has been relying on the
strength of the bishops all game long so
to finish with this checkmate is amazing
and he is going to get that checkmate
basically in after rook takes b6 magnus
has the rook and the bishop under attack
but he plays rook to e8 check which got
a brilliant annotation from game review
so he sacrifices the rook to open up the
bishop to take f6 and fedex resigned
here but of course at this point the
finish is forced rook takes
and then bishop takes actually black
could move the king but then you lose
the rook on a8 so the checkmate is
really kind of the most direct main line
amazing amazing stuff from magnus
if you like this video you will probably
also love this other video about an
amazing magnus carlson blitz game
actually in that game he does come out
on the worst side but he is an
incredible sport about it and the game
ultimately won the chess.com immortal
game prize